[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour ce
troisième débat des législatives dans
les yvelines sur tv fil 78 aujourd'hui
ce sont les candidats de la troisième
circonscription qui vont revenir sur
quelques points de leur programme pour
vous aider à trancher lors du premier
tour de scrutin le dimanche 11 juin la
3e circonscription qui couvre notamment
le chaînage chavenay les
clayes-sous-bois ou encore et pas
seulement à la celle-saint-cloud vous
allez voir la liste complète des
candidats 14 ils sont 14 à se présenter
tous n'ont pas souhaité participer
néanmoins pour des raisons techniques
nous avons dû structurer cette émission
autour de deux grands partis chacun des
candidats sera chronométrée dans ses
réponses pour assurer au mieux l égalité
entre chacun pour débuter j'accueille
philippe brillault candidats à l'est
républicain
bonjour à vous la face à vous et nicolas
eu beau jour candidat du parti
socialiste stéphanie de bonneville
bonjour vous êtes candidat du front
national également face à vous nicolas
attardé joubert bonjour vous êtes
candidat divers droite dans la troisième
circonscription soutenu par le parti
chrétien-démocrate à vos côtés un mari
durant ce maître candidate diverses
c'est comme ça que la préfecture a
retenu votre appellation c'est le parti
du vote blanc
néanmoins pour avec le soutien du parti
du vote blanc et de think tank libre
acteurs pour président s'est précisée
pardon votre candidature et puis à tarek
scalliet également bonsoir à vous vous
êtes directeur de campagne d'alexandre
l'angoissé le candidat de la france en
libye
dans cette troisième circonscription qui
n'a pas pu être présent on va faire un
premier tour de table avec vous en avez
maintenant l'habitude depuis le début de
ces débats un premier tour de table et
cette question est simple pourquoi les
électeurs devraient doivent vous faire
confiance pour ce scrutin pourquoi voter
pour vous en quelques instants
je t'ai profil et brio tout simplement
parce que je suis un candidat
d'expériences locales et qu' il est
indispensable dans l'est
jours et semaines qui viennent qu'au
niveau national on prenne des décisions
et qui soit conforme aux attentes
locales de proximité je crois que nous
avons eu trop d'années bien éloignée de
la proximité et avec des lois qui ne
répondait pas à la tente des personnes
je pense que rien que déjà pour cela ça
me paraît être une raison motivée et
puis tout repart bien évidemment pour
représenter les parties que vous avez
indiqué que je représente une droite
sociale une droite de centre et toutes
ces raisons font que j'aurais
effectivement une vocation à être le
représentant d'un maximum d'habitants de
cette circonscription
le parti socialiste bonsoir et bien moi
je vais vous donner trois raisons
simples de voter pour moi la clarté la
cohérence et la responsabilité la clarté
parce que je pense qu'aujourd'hui on vit
une période un peu trouble et le nouveau
président élu il ya quelques semaines a
fait ses premières armes sur politique
sur les bancs de la gauche
une fois à peine investi celui-ci
investi au sein des ministères un peu
clés que sont le premier d'entre eux
ministère du budget l'économie ou
l'éducation nationale par exemple
investi des hommes de droite
je pense qu'aujourd'hui
notre pays a besoin d'un peu plus de
clarté que ça et j'aspire à apporter
avec mes convictions de gauche un peu
plus de clarté que le président de la
république ne veut bien le laisser en ce
moment la cohérence parce que
précisément je suis un homme de gauche
un homme qui me présente sur mes valeurs
et mes convictions de gauche
j'ai réussi sur la circonscription a
rassemblé l'ensemble des partis de
gauche derrière ma candidature hormis
une une force ici présentes qui n'a pas
souhaité forcément ce vendredi et l'idée
pour moi et évidemment que la gauche
n'est plus forte que plus lorsqu'elle
est rassemblée et unie derrière un seul
candidat
donc c'est la cohérence et la
responsabilité parce que mon mandat si
je suis élu je le passerai évidemment
sur la la l'exigence sur l'aspect
constructif de devoirs que nous avons
envers des envers nos concitoyens
d'apporter le plus d'éclairage et le
plus de projets forts dans leur
direction responsabilités parce que nous
devons aussi entamé les grandes
mutations de demain qu'elle soit
écologique social et environnement il
faut un cerveau ne prenez pas trop en
avance pour avoir du temps pour vous
exprimer sur les autres thématiques qui
vont suivre stéphanie de bonneville
c'est à vous pourquoi les électeurs
devraient vous faire confiance
alors d'abord parce que aux élections
présidentielles marine le pen a
rassemblé plus de 11 millions
d'électeurs que la fête du front
national donc le premier parti de france
une fois encore et donc c'est important
de d'être une véritable force
d'opposition au pouvoir en place qui
effectivement aujourd'hui est un doux
mélange de la droite et de la gauche
donc cette véritable opposition et donc
le principe même de la démocratie de
notre pays
ensuite je vais rappeler évidemment les
trois thèmes fondamentaux de la campagne
présidentielle
parce que contrairement à ce qu'elle dit
monsieur brio je ne pense pas que les
législatives soient des élections de
proximité
ils ce sont des élections qui doivent
représenter au mieux la population et
pour cela il faut
les trois thèmes de du débat
présidentiel c'est à dire le
protectionnisme intelligent
la lutte contre l'insécurité qui
malheureusement évidemment est à l'ordre
du jour est la priorité nationale
on passe à un nicolas tardif joubert
pardon candidat divers droite
bonjour donc moi je suis un homme
d'entreprise expérimenté
j'ai travaillé en france et à l'étranger
et j'ai été élu il y à peu près 18 mois
sur la liste de valérie pécresse avec
l'étiquette du parti chrétien démocrate
et je souhaite aujourd'hui m'engager
davantage en politique je souhaite
j'ai sollicité l'investiture des
républicains ainsi turquie a été
attribué à philippe brillault et je
souhaite renouveler l'offre politique à
droite avec des gens qui sont issus de
la société civile qui ont aussi
légitimité politique parce qu'ils sont
ils ont déjà une première expérience je
connais beaucoup d'élus et qui
souhaitent pouvoir servir le pays
mon objectif avec cette candidature
c'était vraiment de pouvoir voter des
lois qui permettront de remettre le pays
sur des rails il ya beaucoup de choses à
faire et travailler également avec les
maires de notre commune nous avons cent
seize mille habitants et moi je ferai
comme je lé fais en entreprise quand
j'étais dans le secteur international
c'est à dire que je prends l'engagement
de réunir trois fois par an les maires
de nos treize communes pour écouter ce
qu'ils ont à dire quels sont les sujets
qu'ils veulent voir porter est ce que
peut faire le député pour influencer
s'il ya besoin d'aller voir le préfet je
serai là également
donc c'est une présence de proximité
pour faire en sorte que la population
soit bien représenté à l'assemblée
nationale avec mon slogan de campagne
qui est une france droite est honnête et
fière de ce qu'elle est fière de ce
qu'elle transmet tarik kayem je rappelle
que vous êtes représentant directeur de
campagne d'alexandre langlois pour la
france un service pourquoi voter pour
votre candidat
tout d'abord notre candidat exxon
l'emploi et est un policier très engagé
qui a su cerner les qu'elle sut trouver
quelques propositions pour améliorer la
sic
et il tient vraiment à ce que la
sécurité soit un fort également pour
nous il est essentiel de redonner un
souffle nouveau
pas de repos aux agriculteurs ou est
aussi ou aux salariés aux employés leur
redonner espoir et qu'est-ce qui est
aussi nous souhaitons axé notre campagne
sur l'accessibilité pour les personnes
handicapées et nous souhaitons et nous
souhaitons surtout qu'il y ait un débat
au sein de notre circonscription que ça
ne soit pas seulement comment vous dire
ce que c'est que ce soit ouvert et qu'il
n'y ait pas d'à priori
voilà marie durand semaine pour terminer
ce premier tour de table
c'est à vous oui donc en fait je veux
les inscrits sont mes affiches en fait
je souhaite rassembler dans ma
candidature des gens qui en ont assez
des dynasties politiques installés qui
en ont assez des comportements des
députés traditionnelle dans l'hémicycle
qui sauf qu'il faut se faire des
réformes pour notre pays qu'elles sont
nécessaires qui veulent donner une
chance au nouveau président de la
république pour autant ont des doutes
sur certains points de son programme
ou sur la sincérité de sa démarche et
qui sauf que pour être pour avoir un
député pour qu'il soit opérationnel il
faut qu'il ait déjà une expérience de la
sphère publique et qu'ils sont
conscients qu'il sera intéressant
d'avoir dans cette nouvelle assemblée
nationale des gens qui seront
constructifs mais vigie sur des points
qui sont sensibles du programme et qui
pourront alerter le citoyen quand il le
faudra
sur des dérives autoritaires ou autres
qu'on peut pouvoir enfin on peut deviner
voilà et je pense que l'expérience
locale que j'ai de conseil municipal
j'ai été huit ans conseillère municipale
dont le conseil de monsieur brio dans
l'opposition mais une opposition
constructive
je pense qu'on peut faire la même chose
un autre niveau
au niveau national et surtout
pouvoir aussi exercer son mandat au
niveau local le député ne doit pas
négliger la partie locale la première
thématique à présent de ce débat du
premier tour dans la troisième
circonscription thématique a été retenu
c'est la réforme du droit du travail
scellant des sujets prioritaires pour le
nouveau président élu emmanuel macron
veut mener sa réforme au pas de charge
objectif que tout soit bouclé pour le 20
septembre ce sont les rumeurs qui ont
filtré
en tout cas on annonce parmi les
différentes mesures le plafonnement des
indemnités prud'homales en cas de
licenciement abusif
une fusion des instances représentatives
du personnel ou encore un accro à un
accord de branche pour fixer le seuil de
déclenchement être des heures
supplémentaires j'aimerai connaitre vos
opinions et puis aussi vos propositions
dans ce domaine
philippe brillault vous avez un peu plus
de retard vous avez d'ailleurs un petit
peu en dessous de la minute du temps de
parole alors que les autres ont tous
dépassé la minute on va commencer avec
vous est ce que vous faites partie de
ceux au sein des républicains d'ailleurs
qui vont soutenir cette démarche
emmanuel macron parce qu'il y en a alors
comme j'ai du retard très rapidement de
cette émission a pour vocation de
permettre aux électeurs de se faire une
opinion sur chacun de nous deux titres
marque
ma collègue par rapport au front
national qui dit que la proximité c'est
pas ça le débat alors qu'elle parle de
sécurité si la sécurité c'est pas de la
proximité
je ne sais pas comment ça s'appelle le
deuxième sens par rapport à nicolas
tardy c'est de dire qu'il ira voir tous
les maires je lui indique quand même que
tous les maires de la circonscription
sont plutôt à mes côtés pour ce faire
donc voilà c'était juste pour dire que
aujourd'hui les maires sinon ce sera de
voir travailler bien évidemment n'était
pas élu et que je peux bien évidemment
mais je pense que c'est important de
dire qu'une bonne adhésion des mères
déjà sur la façon dont je veux
travailler sur les vous avez rattrapé
réforme barolle partons sans l'arrêter
dans sa campagne pour la réforme c'est
pour ça je m'étais garde un peu de
ressources sur le travail moi je suis
favorable
tout ce que propose le président bak
rond en tout cas sur ces éléments ce qui
montrerait d'ailleurs que le président
macron est plus à droite qu'à gauche
c'est quand même déjà rassurant pour
nous en tout cas peut-être moins un peu
pour les personnes de gauche même si
parmi ces candidats il ya au moins 350
candidats ancien socialiste alors sur le
travail
je crois que ce qui est important c'est
de donner de la liberté aux chefs
d'entreprise pour favoriser l'emploi je
pense que ce qui est proposé me convient
très bien que le système de l'ordonance
est constitutionnellement
crédible puisque l'article 38 permet de
le faire c'est une délégation
gouvernement mais qui doit être validé
par le parlementaire donc que les
électeurs soient rassurés philippe
brillault votre tracé ordonnance sur les
trois thèmes tels que vous venez de le
dire
simplification des représentants du
personnel sur les trois sujets délégués
du personnel comité d'entreprise et les
comités de sécurité des chsct et pour le
reste bien évidemment de pouvoir
encadrer les indemnités prud'homale
il faut donner de la souplesse à
l'économie pour redonner de l'emploi
pour redonner un peu d'allant à ce pays
qui est en train de mourir voilà donc je
suis favorable
et puis sur vos propositions autour de
cette réforme du droit du droit du
travail qu'il faut réformer le droit du
travail
oui alors bien sûr il faut réformer le
droit du travail je pense que la
première chose à dire c'est que
l'économie doit être au service de
l'homme très clairement les justes dans
la prochaine micro et de ne pas
l'enlever parce que là il va s'exprimer
à fond depuis longtemps donc quelques
demidoff au sacerdoce donc allégé
évidemment le coût du travail mais
l'objectif c'est de travailler mieux
pour vivre mieux donc quand aux
ordonnances je pense que le parlement
doit différer donc moi en étant au
parlement je demanderai un débat complet
parce que le dialogue social est une
source d'apaisement et d'améliorations
collective
donc je dis non aux ordonnances ensuite
sur les différentes mesures
les accords de branche entreprise il
faut avoir des accords de branche et non
pas d'accord d'entreprise parce que
sinon on isole le salarié passe à son
patron alors qu'il ya une certaine
égalité au niveau de la branche sur le
plafonnement des indemnités
chaque cas est particulier il n'y a pas
à contraindre la négociation quant au
référendum d'entreprise je dis oui mais
à certaines conditions et notamment il
faut qu'il y ait un que rome pour que ce
soient représentatifs au niveau de
l'entreprise et enfin sur la fusion des
instances représentatives du personnel
dans le cadre d'une us d'une unité
économique sociale oui mais avec une
remontée des seuils sociaux donc il y a
des bonnes choses avec des sondés oui
mais il ya des choses auxquelles je
serais opposé
tarik cayenne j'imagine que cette
libéralisation pour la france est
soumise vous n'y est pas favorable
oui parce que on est contrôleur lui
béret lui brisa sur la société à aix est
ce qu'on veut on veut que ce soit plus
juste parce que par exemple on peut
prendre l'exemple des taxis et taxis ou
une concurrence déloyale par exemple à
cause du père et justement ça crée de
l'emploi
mais ça a créé la pauvreté en même temps
donc il faut feu de la flexibilité mais
faut pas non plus faut pas non plus que
ce soit au détriment de l'emploi du
salarié et pour nous ce qu'on peut faire
dans cette circonscription
on souhaite redonner favoriser les pme
et elle donner envie aux sociétés
d'investir dans cette circonscription et
de on veut redynamiser en redonnant
redynamiser la circonscription
enfin hormis dans l'écologie par exemple
pas être un moteur de croissance
nicolas eu pour continuer sur la vision
de la gauche de ces réformes ne s'engage
à vous savez quand on quand on veut tuer
son chien on dit qu'il a vous la rage
moi ce que je pense précisément c'est
que le souci principal est majeur dans
notre pays c'est la question de l'emploi
est ce que c'est en réglant la question
du code du travail que l'on réglera la
question de l'emploi en france je ne
suis vraiment pas certain inversée pour
moi la hiérarchie des normes telles que
ça allait proposer tel que ça avait déjà
été fait dans l'ancien par l'ancien
ministre macro avec classe et ses
acolytes à l'époque
comment il notamment c'est précariser
encore un peu plus les agents les
salariés et c'est rendre vulnérable
malheureusement les salariés de notre
pays
je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas ça
qu'il faut qu'il faut que l'on se faire
quoi il faut qu'on tende ou bien au
contraire
tout comme la réforme le plafonnement
des indemnités prix d'aumale je pense
que pour le coup comme le disait
monsieur tardy jaubert chaque cas est
différent et on ne peut pas forcément
légiférer dans un seul sens et avec une
seule une seule somme qui serait la même
pour tous alors que les cas sont
évidemment différent il ya un problème
de méthode et un problème de fond
problème de méthode c'est le recours aux
ordonnances sans pouvoir en discuter à
l'assemblée nationale fin il me semble
quand même que c'est le le moyen idoine
pour pouvoir justement débattre de ces
ses colères de ses doigts qui sont
fondamentales pour notre pays et c'est
aussi un problème de fond parce que
précisément lorsque l'on est de gauche
monsieur rioux le rappelait il
semblerait qu'il ait un petit peu moins
de gauche aujourd'hui chez emmanuel
macron qu'hier mais lorsqu'on est de
gauche
ce à quoi on doit s'astreindre c'est
avant tout parce que nos concitoyens
vivent mieux
hier aujourd'hui qu'hier stéphanie
bonneville pour le front national et
ensuite je dirais c'est pas parce qu'on
fait partie d'une force d'opposition
qu'on va forcément tout jeter à la
poubelle des initiatives pour réformer
aujourd'hui les structures en place
n'est pas une mauvaise chose
en revanche je pense qu'effectivement il
faut maintenir le laisser y ait autant
que faire se peut de maintenir le
pouvoir d'achat de notre population ce
qui est aujourd'hui le moindre est
d'être le cas ce pouvoir d'achat
s'effondre depuis au moins une quinzaine
d'années d'une manière colossale et la
précarisation augmente énormément donc
là dessus je pense qu'il ya encore
effectivement beaucoup de travail pour
maintenir
je pense le temps de travail à 35 heures
au peut-être avoir une certaine
souplesse vis-à-vis d'eux
entreprises et nos chefs d'entreprise et
pouvoir l'augmenter par secteur
d'activité avec des négociations mais 30
plus de 35 heures travaillées plus de 35
heures payées
voilà il faut être dans dans une
certaine justice des choses et puis
différencier également les petites et
moyennes entreprises et les grosses
entreprises qui n'ont pas à souffrir des
mêmes problématiques
marie durand smet vous qui êtes un peu à
l'écart des formations politiques avec
votre candidature quel regard vous
portez sur les réformes qui s'engagent
sur ce qu'ils étaient un petit peu dit
je crois en la lucidité la lucidité du
citoyen qui sait qu'il faut repenser
notre modèle social qui sait qu'il ya de
nouvelles formes de travail à toute
forme de travailleurs à prendre en
compte donc faire évoluer la législation
d'ailleurs les français ils sont
favorables à 50% pour des vraies
réformes de fond 45 pensent qu'il faut
des petits aménagements il ya 6 % qui
pensent qu'il faut le stade du cros
seulement
donc ça veut dire que les français sont
plus lucides qu'on ne le pense est plus
favorable à ses réformes dans les
réformes qui sont proposées par le
président de la république il ya des
bons éléments
donc je dirais dans son sens sur
certaines des réformes comme tout ce qui
est réforme de la formation
professionnelle l'allègement des charges
sociales est également tout ce qui est
référendum d'entreprise
en revanche je serais beaucoup plus
vigilantes sur tout ce qui est les
prud'hommes les sentiments abusif
là il faut protéger les les salariés
je serai très vigilante sur ces points
là on va voir dans un instant les temps
de parole qui vont s'afficher vous êtes
tous à peu près autour des 2 minutes 30
un peu plus de trois minutes par contre
pour nicolas eu voilà on va on va voir
les temps qui qui s'affiche avoir à vous
parler un tout petit peu plus que les
autres ce soir d'un casque ayem qui a
aussi un petit peu plus de de retard
néanmoins la prochaine thématique c'est
là c'est la sécurité
vous vous lire encore vous évoquer la
question de l'emploi oui moi je voudrais
juste eu brièvement que la baisse des
charges sociales n'est pas la seule
solution il faut sortir le financement
du social de la santé du salariat et de
l'économie moi je pense que la tva
sociale était une bonne chose les
allemands ont fait il faut y revenir et
y penser je pense qu'il faudrait tester
la tva sociale de manière à ce qu'ils
aient un transfert des charges des
entreprises vers la consommation
absolument moi je suis j'ai trente
secondes jeu juste un indice à l'élite
jeu juste qu'on imagine aussi le monde
de demain et qu'on imagine les mutations
sociales et les mutations économiques
notamment dans le domaine du travail
quand mark zuckerberg ou bill gates de
grands entrepreneurs vente des mérites
que certains cas secondes certains
prenaient encore quelques semaines à
peine et que là où les regarde comme des
des très bonnes mesures
alors qu'elle n'avait pas forcément
rencontré un écho favorable il ya
quelques temps je pense qu'il faut
vraiment regarder les mutations de
demain à l'aune de ces déclarations m'a
parler de sécurité à présent ensuite
vous aurez votre carte blanche le sujet
sur lequel vous souhaitez vous exprimer
et et mettre en avant le sujet que vous
souhaitez mettre en avant dans cette
campagne en mode sécurité parce que le
manchester vous le savez il ya eu
récemment un attentat une nouvelle fois
emmanuel macron prévoit de son côté la
création imminente d'une task force à
l'elysée un dispositif de plus dans la
lutte anti terrorisme et puis il ya cet
état d'urgence qui a été prolongée a
commencé avec vous pour la france à 1
soumises en matière de sécurité
est-ce que ce qui se dessine ce qui va
se mettre en place peut être un atout
supplémentaire ou au contraire est-ce
que vous portez d'autres propositions
je pense que c'est une très mauvaise
idée
et toute façon peu importe
no peu importe si on est de droite ou de
gauche
la question sécuritaire est essentiel
parce qu'on ne peut plus peut plus vivre
sereinement et je pense que pour que
qu'on puisse être protégé sereinement
il faut qu'on vous qui a un travail
constructif à l'assemblée et pas
d'opposition stérile parce que c'est
vraiment un débat très important
la société et je pense que ce qu'il faut
c'est déjà augmenté l'arsenal l'arsenal
juridique en donnant des peines plus
comment dire plus plus on et d'équations
avec cet accord ses actes
et si on souhaite qu'on souhaite créer
je pense que le mieux c'est de mettre
davantage d des prisons se séparer pour
les détenus radicaliser népalais ne pas
les mettre au contact aux détenus qui
sont là pour des peines par exemple pour
des contraventions non pas des
contraventions pour des délits mineurs
voilà et je pense que l'essentiel pour
lutter contre le terrorisme et de lutter
contre le communautarisme par le biais
d'associations et bien sûr l'éducation
je vois plutôt d'accord ah oui mais oui
absolument mais ça la montée du
communautarisme n'est effectivement pas
très bon signe pour la sécurité et
l'immigration massive est évidemment non
plus donc il semble important de lutter
encore contre c'est contre ces deux
fléaux pour retrouver une certaine
sérénité
quelles sont les propositions que vous
portez spécifiquement barrière de
sécurité déjà les fichiers sd jade et ça
ça me paraît absolument inouïe qu'il
reste encore sur notre territoire
alors c'est déjà une première chose
ensuite fermer les mosquées
extrémistes ne pas attendre les
incidents surveiller les financements de
pays comme le qatar comme les pays du
golfe ça c'est aussi essentiel je crois
que deux il ya deux ou trois jours
il ya une perquisition dans une radio
puisque des mouvements de fonds suspects
ont interrogé nous nous nos policiers
donc là je crois qu'il faut absolument
être extrêmement ferme sur cette
question je me tourne vers vous pas ce
que l'on me donne en même temps les
indications de temps de parole et
j'essaye de répartir au mieux entre vous
à marie durand ce matin ce qu'a dit
tarek en matière de sécurité
aussi ce que vous avez dit sur les
mosquées extrémistes je pense
qu'effectivement de puteaux les récents
et lutter contre tous les extrémistes et
les communautarismes
en revanche pour moi quand je parle de
sécurité je vois d'autres thèmes de
domaine qui se voit la sécurité
alimentaire et sanitaire dont on ne
parle pas beaucoup
la sécurité vis-à-vis des risques
naturels la sécurité au travail
mais en revanche pour tout ce qui est
sécurité des personnes et des biens au
sens du droit public je partais ce qui a
été dit les briauds votre opinion sur ce
qui met en place cette task force par
exemple écoutez moi j'ai entendu le
représentant de france aso mise pour
dire la droite et la gauche et la corsa
sécurité oui sur les objectifs c'est à
dire donner la garantie aux aux français
de vivre en toute tranquillité
mais ça n'a pas été le cas avec les cinq
ans que nous venons de vivre au niveau
du socialisme en fait excuser moi on est
en a été avec des mesures de laxisme
permanent et aujourd'hui s'épandent
augmentant la police en augmentant les
places de prison que l'on va traiter le
problème c'est un petit peu comme la
santé c'est pas parce que vous avez des
médicaments pour les symptômes que vous
avez traité la cause c'est donc bien en
amont qu'il faut prendre des décisions
1 je pense qu'il faut légiférer pour
donner des précisions sur les
différentes forces de l'ordre qui existe
la gendarmerie la police nationale et
c'est régis les polices municipales on
voit bien que on est en train de
transférer de plus en plus sa sécurité
aux élus locaux
les polices municipales les armes et où
donc je crois qu'il faut qu'on essaye
peut-être d'avoir une loi qui soit
beaucoup plus clair
déjà sur ces points et puis les fiches s
comment peut-on avoir dans une commune à
simple de fish est connu et de se dire
j'en attends de voir qu'il fasse une
connerie pour à ce moment là non non il
faut pour clarifie bien les choses sur
les étrangers sur le sol qui ont fait
l'objet de peines qui sont il faut faire
du nettoyage
oui sans réserve voilà et c'est valable
aussi bien pour les français qui va
aussi avoir des fiches et d'autres
mesures en a plein mais du coup ça prend
deux mais mon temps j'arrête
voilà ils vont garder du temps pour la
carte blanche après nicolas tardy
joubert c'est à vous plus de retards
allaient venir m'établir l'autorité de
l'état c'est la première chose on a vu
ces cinq dernières années à laxisme
judiciaire absolument incroyable quand
même madame taubira était la collègue au
gouvernement de monsieur emmanuel macron
on l'a pas vu se dessiner des risées
aujourd'hui nous avons un déficit de
places de prison il ya une surpopulation
carcérale donc la première chose à faire
c'est aussi c'est de créer des places de
prisons d'abord que pour que ces détenus
puissent vivre dignement dans leur
présence et je puis dire mais il faut
surtout assurer la sécurité sur tous les
territoires de la république c'est à
dire que ça commence
il faut prendre le mal à la racine la
chose auquel il faut penser à traiter
c'est éliminer les trafics de drogue de
drogue avoir une tolérance zéro qu'il
n'y ait plus de territoires perdus dans
la république c'est assurer l'exécution
des peines ce pauvre xavier gillet qui a
été tué sur les champs elysées l'a été
par une personne qui aurait dû être en
prison jusqu'en 2020 bon je sais c'est
pas très compliqué de chercher l'erreur
donc il faut que les peines soient
exécutées qu'il y ait également une
double peine c'est à dire qu'à la fin de
la peine
un étranger soit expulsé comme c'est
fait dans d'autres démocraties je pense
par exemple au danemark
et enfin je pense qu'il ya un consensus
sur le fait qu'il faut fermer les
mosquées salafistes qui sont liées à
l'uejf parce que le loup y es faits
considérés comme une organisation
terroriste dans un centre d'état en
egypte pays musulman donc il y à un
laxisme
il faut prendre les mesures adéquates je
suis désolé mais le gouvernement
précédent on n'a pas pris ces mesures
donc nous retrouver dans une situation
où la france gère nos concitoyens ne
sont pas en sécurité
marie durand semaine je me retourne vers
vous parce que vous avez un peu plus de
retard si vous souhaitez vous exprimer
encore sur la question de la sécurité
ensuite le maître mot c'est la
prévention que ce soit tous types de
sécurité il faut vraiment que le travail
soit fait sur la prévention
parce qu'il est mieux de faire ça plutôt
deux les réparations coûtent beaucoup
plus cher
voilà donc maître mot devrait être très
anciens nicolas d'avancé la prévention
qui va me permettre de rebondir aussi
dessus puisque je semble avoir été mise
en cause de la à travers les tic est que
je représente
non mais évidemment mais je je je tiens
quand même à souligner enfin moi je suis
assez stupéfait de vos réactions
nous avons tous un objectif qui est
évidemment de faire en sorte que nos
concitoyens puissent vivre dans
l'harmonie et la bienveillance où qu'ils
soient et où qu'ils se présentent
par contre je suis vraiment super
stupéfait par votre constat puisque
comme comme tentiez de le rappeler la
droite et la gauche ce n'est pas la même
chose lorsque nous avons pris lorsque
françois hollande a pris les rênes du
pays en 2012
c'était 12 mille policiers en moins
c'était une police de proximité qui
n'existait plus c'était des
renseignements généraux des services de
renseignements généraux qui avaient
totalement péricliter moi je suis
complètement stupéfait aujourd'hui je
suis complètement stupéfait aujourd'hui
mais monsieur brio vous allez me parler
aussi de votre résultat à vous en tant
que conseiller départemental puisque
madame marie diron madame marie durand
nous parlait de la prévention et moi je
reviens sur la prévention spécialisée
qui a mis à mal la prévention
spécialisée vous nature brio vous
connaissez très bien départementaux
connaissez très le conseil départemental
auquel vous appartenez a mis à mal la
prévention spécialisée dans le nicolas
vous pouvez me reconnaître quelque chose
ici la poussière du temps pour votre
carte blanche chez librio je vous laisse
répondre et ensuite on devine si elles
le souhaitent pour rattraper le retard
je réponds très très rapidement le
président hollande il a réussi à
fracturer complètement la gauche et le
parti socialiste ils sont partis un côté
macro un côté à - quote ça a
complètement explosé on dirait de notre
côté aussi peut-être un peu moins au
niveau de la solidarité pour les
législatives
en tout cas à gauche c'est vrai qu'on a
du mal à y voir clair moi je ne suis
candidat pour essayer de voir clair
justement sur l aire lui dit et tous
ceux qui ont adhéré à ses valeurs et ses
projets mais le terrorisme a aussi
augmenté en intensité ces dernières
années faut être honnête
en fin d'année on n'a pas fait grand
chose non plus pour lutter contre ce
terrorisme en état d'urgence
en tout cas et nous sommes encore en
état d'urgence
malheureusement monsieur je pense qu'on
ne peut pas rire de tout et on ne peut
pas réagir ces sujets là on ne peut pas
rire sur ce sujet là comme vous semblez
le faire
moi je pense très simplement qu'à un
moment donné il faut aussi arrêter avec
l'espèce de démagogie qui qui est la
mise sur l'inscription il rendit qui est
mise là sur le plateau et que
l'immigration n'est pas source de tout
je pense je pense je prie le contrat
vous avez laissé entendre ça je pense
aujourd'hui j'ai laissé entendre qu'il
fallait je mange entre une immigration
massive ans aujourd'hui qu'il faut que
vous regardiez c'est le nombre de
personnes issues d'origines autre que
c'est le professeur les hyades française
d'origine qui défonce est sûre notre
riche idée
monsieur et jose 1 sur forever now un
mot peut-être pour la france insoumise
vous êtes un petit peu en retard le
temps parle on va revoir à l'issue de
votre intervention les chronomètres de
chacun pour que vous puissiez un peu
calibré vos interventions sur la carte
blanche ce que vous avez demandé avant
de passer ensuite déjà aux conclusions à
l'isie voulait surtout ce que vous avez
un peu entendu jusqu'à maintenant je ya
comment dire par rapport au terrorisme
je pense que la droite et la gauche ont
quand même une responsabilité les deux
côtés parce que on ne peut pas le nier
il ya eu des attentats dont quelles
responsabilités des deux côtés le poste
et je ce qu'il faut c'est si les
commissions je pense t commission
parlementaire pour pour coller pour que
cela ne se reproduise pas par exemple on
peut pas elle ne peut pas admettre dans
un état comme la france que atténue se
retrouvent dans la nature qui devrait
être en prison
et ce qui me semble essentiel c'est la
coopération des services de police je
pense que c'est la base pour une
meilleure lutte contre le terrorisme
quoi on va voir donc les temps de parole
pendant qu'ils s'affichent avait tout de
suite vous passez la parole marie durand
smet pour cette partie carte blanche le
sujet que vous avez choisi de mettre en
avant
maintenant on les voir ces temps de
parole
on voit que quand on a eu un peu plus
d'avancé avec avec philippe brillault
voilà également donc marie durand se
mettant on vous écoute après ce sera
nicolas tardy joubert également
s'éteindra pas comme un carton sur la
moralisation de la vie publique en fait
huit ans que je milite sur cet aspect là
la vie politique oui en fait mon
engagement au début c'était voilà on a
commencé à militer là dessus en créant
politique mois déjà dans le nom le nom
en disait long et nous militions pour le
non cumul des mandats la maîtrise de la
longévité politique également
l'exemplarité des élus
le premier qui met les mains dans le pot
de confiture inéligible à vie
là aussi on doit être plus stricts voilà
donc en fait voilà en ce moment on parle
de moralisation de la vie publique ne
suffit pas de le dire et de l'affiché
encore faut-il l'incarner et j'ai un peu
des doutes continuent d affaires en ce
moment
sur certains profils voilà donc c'est
pour ça que je pense qu'ils se trouvent
être démissionnés par exemple oui je
suis surprise quand même alors qu'on
affiche cette volonté de moralisation de
la vie politique que dès les premières
semaines
on voit des affaires comme celle de
monsieur ferrand et puis aussi dans les
investitures qui ont été donnés je suis
surprise aussi de certains profils de la
probité de certains voient là et je vais
rappeler que l'ensemble des candidats de
cette circonscription comme dans les
autres circonscriptions a été invité sur
ce plateau notamment à le représentant
de la république en marche qui n'était
pas disponible pour participer au débat
voilà puisqu'elle lui parla pour
notamment représenté mouvement et et
vous répondre nicolas tardif joubert
c'est à vous alors je pense que ma carte
blanche je pense qu'il faut vraiment
agir en faveur de la solidarité
aujourd'hui on a quasiment 6 millions de
chômeurs en france on a neuf millions de
pauvres je voudrais juste rappeler qu'un
pauvre c'est quelqu'un qui vit avec 60%
du revenu médian ce qui fait à peu près
mille euros que nous avons 2,2 millions
de gens très pauvres qui vivre avec
moins de 600 euros et qu'un agriculteur
sur trois selon la source
aimé ça être gagnent moins de 350 euros
par mois donc il ya vraiment des choses
à faire ça est multifactorielle bien
évidemment je pense qu'il faut mettre un
plan en place pour lutter contre la
provôté pour permettre j'aurai à nos
concitoyens d'accéder à un travail parce
qu'à partir du moment un travail on
déclenche le gérer la sortie de ce
tunnel qui est très compliqué à avoir un
logement pouvoir se soigner et c'est
donc première chose vrai qu'on facilité
comme encourage la formation
professionnelle tout au long de la vie
avec un apprentissage possible à tout
âge voilà c'est une première chose qui
permettrait d'avoir un retour à l'emploi
la deuxième chose je pense qu'il faut
faciliter l'accès au logement social
c'est à dire qu'il faut réduire les
droits de mutation aujourd'hui sont
quasiment à 6% en france moi j'ai
travaillé en suède c'était à deux et
demi pour cent c'est à 2 % en autriche
dont il faut faire en sorte que les gens
puissent acheter plus facilement
et puis réduire la tva pour la première
acquisition pour le logement
il faut aussi soutenir les services
publics et les petits commerçants en
zone rurale et dans nos villages c'est à
dire que pour ça pour qu'ils puissent
vivre il faut alléger les charges vers
les tpe et les pme
clairement il ya des gens que j'ai
visitées sur certaines communes qui
disent on n'arrive pas à vivre avec tout
ce que l'on a à supporter et je pense
que le travail doit payer plus que j'ai
l'assistanat il faut faire en sorte
ensuite il faut former si on veut avoir
un axe de solidarité ce qui me semble
très fort c'est pour les personnes
handicapées avoir un grand plan de
formation
avoir des auxiliaires de vie des aides à
domicile et permettre aux gens de rester
chez eux
et enfin si on veut vraiment lutter
contre la pauvreté il ya aussi une chose
à faire qui me semble assez fondamental
c'est à dire qu'ils préfèrent d'établir
la correspondance entre les besoins
sociaux dans un territoire et les offres
de compétences et qu'on puisse déployer
les politiques publiques pour établir le
lien et pour permettre un retour à
l'emploi
sachant que l'emploi c'est ce qui permet
de sortir de ce phénomène de pauvreté
n'hésitez pas à intervenir si vous le
souhaitez aussi réagir sur ce qui a été
dit avant de passer ensuite à votre
carte personnelle je suis assez d'accord
avec tardi joubert a dit concernant
l'emploi
cela dit aujourd'hui on vend on trouve
des gens forte population dans un
système de précarité alors qu'il
travaille et donc l'emploi ne résout pas
tout puisque il travaille mais sont dans
des situations pris effectivement il y
avait visité des marchands de scooter
dans une de nos communes utilisent et je
travaille mais je n'arrive pas à être
les charges pourquoi parce qu'il ya trop
de normes et que j'ai trop de charges
donc il faut réduire les charges pour
les tpe pme
absolument mais c'est vrai que je vais
rebondir sur ce que vous dites parce que
est ce que vous dites madame également
parce que ma carte blanche sera plutôt
sur l'aspect sociétal de notre société
pour moi une société qui va bien c'est
une société qui est bienveillante à
l'égard des de ceux qui sont plus
fragiles les anciens les personnes âgées
les handicapés
je pense qu'une société qui dénigrent
cette population elle va mal et avec les
propositions des malades emmanuel macron
d'une augmentation il assiège
qui va en pâtir le plus ce sont nos
retraités
donc attention voilà attention je pense
qu'il faut il faut regarder cette
société avec les plus fragiles en les
considèrent pas ce jeu passe à vous
aussi vous souhaitez et réagir d'une
part et ensuite passer à votre carte
blanche à un peu plus d'une minute
trente voire de minutes pour pour qu'on
puisse équilibrer un peu plus les temps
de parole
j'ai été je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec votre analyse sur la solidarité
je pense que c'est un axe majeur parce
que on voit la pauvreté et les
difficultés de beaucoup de gens et et il
faut vraiment vraiment agir pour parce
que on voit la souffrance et c'est pas
grave je trouve que c'est pas viable
pour notre société
et moi je voudrais surtout accentué je
voudrais surtout parler de des
handicapés et des étangs et aussi des
personnes âgées
j'estime que les personnes âgées doivent
on doit agir pour eux
est-ce que je pense que le que les
gouvernements précédents n'ont pas fait
assez pour pour rendre leur retraite
plus décentes et aussi riche et aussi
les importants pour pour que les
personnes handicapées puissent juger
sereinement que les aidants soient sort
meilleur son meilleur contact et de
meilleures conditions de travail soient
reconnus soit reconnu surtout et et
voilà philippe brillault c'est avant
quand cette carte blanche
moi c'est une carte bleu blanc rouge je
pense qu'il faut redonner des couleurs
le pays
il faut redonner des couleurs aux
français et pour ce faire
d'abord il faut qu'on arrête d'opposer
les riches et les pauvres
autant sur la pauvreté il faut s'en
occuper
vous savez le dicton asiatiques qui et
quand le riche maigri le pauvre mais je
pense que on a besoin d'argent pour
l'économie
pas besoin de capital pour faire du
social moi je suis pour que la fiscalité
ne soit pas une fiscalité privatives
mais une fiscalité incitative
le logement social ne réglera pas tout
le problème il faut passer participé
avec des avantages fiscaux sur des
logements pour tout le monde
voilà donc fiscalité les ordonnances
pour l'économie et puis redonné
effectivement vous l'avez dit tout tout
est plus je crois sur l'enseignement sur
revenir aux fondamentaux sur le respect
de l'ordre autres tout ça c'est pas très
compliqué il faut prendre des mesures
simples immédiate est que l'on puisse
voir les choses avant la fin de cette
année voilà moi dans quel esprit je
serais si je suis lui dans quelques
jours nicolas c'est à vous je vais vous
demander de faire concis pour complice
on puisse passer aux conclusions
c'est de faire consiste j'aurais aimé
développer un petit peu plus un des
points que je présente sur un dessin que
piliers qui sont pour moi l'urgence
économique ceci sans attendre
conclusions aussi aimerait donc aller
dans la carte blanche il est sur la
carte blanche
moi je voudrais qu'on ait un point d'
alerte intérieur un peu d' alerte
extérieur un point d' alerte au vu de
l'actualité
avec le retrait de des états unis des
accords de paris en termes
environnementaux je pense que c'est un
coin enfoncé par le président américain
et que les européens rôle a toute
latitude et ça doit être un aspect qui
j'espère va consolider l'europe est en
tout cas l'axé franco-allemand pour
porter au mieux ses inspirations dans
une mutation écologique et
environnemental que nous devons hausser
à nos enfants dans un état en tout cas
la terre que nous pouvons laisser dans
un état que vivable pour eux pour les
générations à venir
le deuxième point vite fait c'est
évidemment la question de la
moralisation de la vie publique
on croyait qu'on avait tout vu pendant
les élections présidentielles avec
la sphère fillon malheureusement la
république nouvellement élu en avait
fait son axe de campagne on voit qu'en
quinze jours tout a été réduit à néant
arrête et pour le vin est véritablement
parce que vous allez vraiment dépassé
beaucoup trop longtemps le citoyen là
pour la voir quand même leur mot à dire
sur ce sujet là maurice jarre la
prochaine vraiment si vous ne m'écoutez
pas bon passons aux conclusions de
chacun et de chacune marie durand smet
vous vous débutez vous avez une bonne
minute pour conclure si vous le
souhaitez bien évidemment merci de
l'attention qui met porter ma
candidature est mûrement réfléchi à dos
et des hommes et des femmes qui savent
ce qu'est un mandat électif
c'est un temps de vie que je consacrerai
au collectif vecteur d attente et vigie
des engagements qui sont pris avec aussi
la volonté d'associer les citoyens
c'est ce que propose le parti du vote
blanc au delà de faire reconnaître le
vote blanc comme une exigence
démocratique
utiliser des outils qui nous permettent
aujourd'hui de faire participer le
citoyen aux décisions qui seront prises
et je m'y engage
on passe à la france a soumises ou si
vous le souhaitez vous avez une bonne
minute de conclusion nous nous
souhaitons à travers notre candidat
défendre le bien commun et les intérêts
des citoyens avant tout nous nous avons
nous souhaitons surtout c'est un mandat
est notre essentiel pour nous et d'agir
et d'apporter quelque chose de la
circonscription
on a sonné pas aux menus bébé par par
exemple les bosses tu es tout ça on
souhaite agir
est ce qu'on estime que pour nous la
politique c'est top à se
professionnaliser
elle doit permettre à tout le monde de
pouvoir c'est de pouvoir dire ce qu'il a
à dire et puis et puis de participer à
la vie de la société
donc on l'interdît joubert c'est à vous
trentaine de secondes entre néanmoins c
un peu plus court
je suis un nouvel élu régional et rien
ne m'oblige à laisser mon mandat puisque
je ne suis pas dans l'exécutif mais je
n'envisage pas d'être député ami
donc je vais être a débuté à plein temps
pour travailler en commission pour être
présent dans l'hémicycle pour être
contact de mes concitoyens et donc je
laisserais mon mandat de manière à
pouvoir me consacrer complètement
redressement de la france
je serai en étant à l'assemblée
nationale je veux une france qui soient
humaines sociales qui servent le bien
commun qui défendent aussi le droit des
buffles haybes et droits de l'enfant et
qui rayonne sur le plan international
stéphanie gonneville pour le front
national si vous pouviez concluront peu
moins d'une minute
franchement être une véritable
opposition oui mais patriotes et
bienveillante je crois qu'effectivement
je ne vais pas contredire ce que mes
prédécesseurs on dit parce que c'est
tout tout tout ça est très juste et très
vrai jeu j'adhère complètement
voilà il faut il faut de l'action il
faut de véritables mesures pour la
sécurité pour pouvoir grandir et évoluer
rayonner comme y être un beau pays voilà
nicolas us et votre conclusion que je
saurai pas ce que vous allez m'en
vouloir
si on vingtaine de secondes maximum vous
pouviez conclure moi je vous invite
j'invite mes concitoyens à voter pour
moi et pour la gauche d'avenir et pour
le parti que je représente la gauche
pour répondre à l'urgence économique et
sociale pour garantir des services
publics sur tout notre territoire pour
renouveler notre démocratie pour
envisager la mutation écologique et
environnementale à venir évidemment pour
rendre l'europe au service des peuples
libres il roule c'est à vous pour cette
conclusion moi je dis aux électeurs vous
avez quelques jours pour faire un choix
pour le 11 juin
réveillez vous sortez de vos anesthésie
mois voter pour des gens qui connaissent
les sujets qui ont vite et qui
accompagneront un président qui a la
volonté de faire bouger le pays
ce qui ne veut pas dire pour autant tout
accepter à parlement qui a un
contre-pouvoir c'est essentiel vous
pouvez être sûr que c'est dans ce sens
là que j'agirais merci à tous les six
d'avoir participé à cette première
partie de un débat sur cette troisième
circonscription des yvelines cette
édition spéciale du 7-8 politique le
débat va se poursuivre si on peut juste
revoir les temps de parole avant de
passer au second un plateau voilà sans
surprise certains ont un petit peu plus
d'avancé que d'autres ont essayé au
mieux vous l'avez vue d'équilibrer et je
rappelle les règles du csa c'est ce sont
les règles de l'équité qui s'applique
tout au long de cette campagne donc il
ya aussi les autres émissions pour
équilibrer au mieux tout ça voilà et
tout le monde semble plutôt d'accord
merci à vous
le débat se poursuit a juste après ce
reportage signé nicolas kirilow vide qui
revient sur les enjeux de la
circonscription
henri guaino écartée par les
républicains et 14 candidats espèrent
devenir député de la 3e circonscription
des yvelines c'est 5 de moins qu'en 2012
à l'époque l'ancien conseiller de
nicolas sarkozy l'avait remportée face à
la candidate socialiste fabienne galgon
bilbo avec près de 62% des suffrages
exprimés
critiqué pour son manque
d'investissement sur le terrain henri
guaino n'a pas été investi une nouvelle
fois par son parti le maire du chesnay
philippe brillault lui a reçu le soutien
des ténors locaux est leur candidat pour
la sixième fois d'affilée cet ancien mai
un fait figure de favori pour l'élection
sur un territoire acquis à la droite
depuis plusieurs décennies il souhaite
notamment faire une campagne pour une
fiscalité incitative et sur un meilleur
accès au logement et après avoir été
chasseur philippe brillault est
désormais chasser notamment par le
conseiller régional francilien
nicolas tardy joubert soutenu par le
parti chrétien-démocrate de jean
frédéric poisson lui aussi proche de la
manif pour tous
ce candidat classé divers droite
pourrait récolter de nombreuses voix
dans plusieurs villes où françois fillon
est arrivé en tête au premier tour de la
présidentielle comme à bougival
hors-concours une concurrence à droite
qui pourrait faire les affaires de
béatrice piron la candidate de la
république en marche se présente pour la
première fois à une élection
elle espère surfer sur la vague
présidentielle et du renouveau pour
remporter cette circonscription
urbanisées où le chômage ne dépasse pas
les 9 % une première aussi pour la
candidate du front national stéphanie de
gonneville membre de l'équipe de
campagne de marine le pen il y a cinq
ans elle essaiera de faire mieux qu'en
2012 et les 7,1 pour cent du fn
recueillies sur la circonscription à
gauche les espoirs sont nombreux aussi
le parti socialiste a réussi à sceller
un accord local avec europe ecologie les
verts le parti radical de gauche et le
parti communiste pour soutenir nicolas
eu conseiller municipal des
clayes-sous-bois reste à savoir si cette
unité de la gauche suffira pour se
hisser au second tour de l'élection
comme il y a cinq ans autre binôme qui
souhaitent s'immiscer dans cette course
à la députation celui de la france
insoumise et son candidat alexandre
langlois novice en politique il devrait
largement faire mieux que la candidate
du front de gauche en 2012 qui n'avait
récolté qu'à peine plus de 2 % des voix
le 11 juin jour du premier tour de
l'élection près de 85 mille électeurs
sont appelés à voter pour départager au
total 14 candidats le débat du premier
tour dans cette troisième
circonscription des yvelines se poursuit
ce sont à présent quatre nouveaux
candidats candidate qui nous ont
rejoints tout d'abord petit bo tournier
qui est candidat debout elle la france
bonsoir surface avoue michel lavezzari
candidate nouvelle donne
bonsoir également à sidi ça qu on saura
vous pour représenter 577 pour la france
est également jean michel boeri
bienvenue en plateau candidats de l'upm
donc dans cette troisième
circonscription la règle est la même que
tout à l'heure le temps de parole est
chronométré et vous pouvez bien sûr
échanger aussi elle les uns avec les
autres au fur et à mesure de cette
émission le premier tour de table est
simple pourquoi les électeurs doivent
vous faire confiance
on commence avec vous alors moi je vais
vous donner 5 bonne raison de me faire
confiance et de voter pour moi
la première chose à debout la france
notre priorité c'est de rendre leur
fierté aux français leur fierté d'être
français et d'en finir avec la
repentance mémorielle la deuxième chose
on va en finir avec l'insécurité et pour
ceux ci en finir avec le laxisme
judiciaire
la troisième chose concerne l'économie
alors qu emmanuel macron est le candidat
des multinationales
nous voulons mettre le paquet sur les
pme et sur le made in france
enfin le quatrième point concerne la
question de l'immigration voulu mettre
terme à l'immigration massive qui subit
notre pays depuis tant de décennies
et enfin le dernier point concerne
l'école je veux rétablir une école
exigeante qui donne le goût de l'effort
et en finir avec le nivellement par le
bas
on passe à vous monsieur lavezzari pour
une nouvelle donne écoutez moi je suis
novice en politique je me suis engagé il
ya pas très longtemps pour le parti
nouvelle donne un parti qui a été créée
novembre 2013 donc était à l'origine un
mouvement citoyen est qui
estime qu'il est nécessaire de reprendre
la main après dix années d'échecs aucune
recette n'a vraiment parler de
l'économie réelle et beaucoup de
personnes restent sur le sur le banc je
voulais signaler aussi que moi je coûte
pas très cher comme élus potentiels par
rapport à la masse représenté par le
budget pour par exemple les candidats
dans marche et
j'ai moi je représente seulement 1200
euros et encore avec pas mal d'argent de
ma poche je voudrais éviter aussi les
écueils qui tous ces gens là représente
pour une évolution de notre société
je ne veux pas laisser les édiles
continuer à confisquer le pouvoir et je
constate que dans la campagne électorale
les personnes qui se présentent ont
beaucoup de suppléants qui eux mêmes
on était dans la vie politique et
continue à être actif parce qu'ils ne
peuvent pas prétendre à un second mandat
ou un troisième mandat on continue ce
tour de table avec vous c'est du chaco
pourquoi les électeurs doivent vous
faire confiance alors les électeurs
doivent et peuvent me faire confiance
reste pour la simple et bonne raison que
je suis un citoyen comme tout le monde
autour de la table
un citoyen qui a développé une expertise
durant de nombreuses années qui a été
mise au profit de certains élus de
certaines associations qui est une
expertise sur les politiques
d'innovation et moi si je suis à
l'assemblée nationale ce que je souhaite
c'est regarder tous les textes de loi
pour favoriser la politique une
politique d'innovation globale et
ambitieuse et qui permet nous
accompagner dans une politique générale
pour atteindre les objectifs
environnementaux atteint des objectifs
sociaux et économiques
et puis d'autre part créer une économie
beaucoup plus inclusive que ce qu'elle
n'est jusque là et dans les points c'est
que comme vous l'avez compris je ne fais
pas partie d'un parti politique
ça peut être un tort ou ou pas pour moi
c'est ça me permet d'avoir une
indépendance que je ma profit des
électeurs je suis là pour la réussite de
la france pas pour la réussite des
partis politiques que ce soit de droite
comme de gauche
à partir du moment où il ya une bonne
idée si elle est expérimentée et qu'on
arrive à consulter je défendrai la bonne
idée donc c'est le sens de mon combat
jean michel boury quel est le sens de
votre combat à vous oui ben moi je suis
je représente le père je suis candidat
sur la troisième circonscription et j'ai
rejoint l'ue perdent en 2014 tout
simplement parce que j'ai regardé et
écouté les analyses de françois
asselineau et j'ai vu que ce parti était
constant dans ses propositions et ses
analyses étaient est claire et précise
l'intérêt que je porte et lui perce et
c'est celui d'apporter ma contribution à
la vie publique et d'y apporter de la
moralité plus de justice et une
implication personnelle de de tout ce
qu'ils font partie de la vie civile on
passe à la première thématique qui a été
définie comme lors du premier plateau de
ce débat c'est la réforme du droit du
travail je rappelle que vous aurez aussi
votre carte blanche pour vous exprimer
sur le sujet que vous souhaitez la
question du droit du travail donc sujets
prioritaires
pourquoi nous avons retenu sujet tout
simplement parce que l'objectif pour le
nouveau président élu c'est que les
choses aillent vite que tout soit bouclé
le 20 septembre c'est en tout cas les
rumeurs la rumeur qui court il ya
plusieurs mesures annoncées fusion des
instances représentatives du personnel
accord de branche également pour fixer
le seuil de déclenchement des heures
supplémentaires aussi mais quelques-unes
des mesures qui pourraient être
rapidement mise en place du côté de
debout la france
qu'en pensez vous est ce que c'est une
bonne chose est-ce qu'il faut déjà
réformé est-ce qu'il faut réformer
vitesse que sont bonnes mesures
bon évidemment qu'il ya des choses à
faire dans le monde du travail mais moi
je souhaite surtout alerté mes
concitoyens sur une mesure d' emmanuel
macron qui a été peu médiatisé qui est
la discrimination positive al embauche
alors qu'est ce que c'est
emmanuel macron propose que les
entreprises est une prime lorsqu elles
embauchent
des habitants de quartiers dits
difficiles à on sait tous que ça veut
dire ceci cela veut dire que les
français de souche vont devenir des
citoyens de seconde zone dans leur
propre pays et cette mesure je m'engage
à la combattre fermement l'assemblée
nationale après sur l'économie de
manière plus générale comme j'ai dit
tout à l'heure
nous ce qui nous importe ce sont les pme
et les petits commerces
alors qu'ils menaient une macro est
candidat des multinationales nous on va
prélever les pme puisqu'elles font vivre
notre tissu économique elles ont aussi
un rôle social une pme ça ne
délocalisent pas une pme ça ne cherche
pas à faire d'évasion fiscale est une
pme ça permet aux français de vivre et
travailler au pays et donc pour ça nous
on veut en finir avec tout ce qui
pourrit la vie des patrons pme c'est à
dire on veut en finir avec les taxes qui
s'adresse qui s'abat tueur est en
permanence en finir avec les normes en
finir avec les contrôles inutile d
incessants qui le subissent
et puis dans les choses récentes et bien
on veut on veut en finir avec le
prélèvement à la source qui va encore
pourrir la vie des patrons et le conte
pénibilité qui est vraiment à castets
sans fin pour eux n'hésitez pas je vous
le disais une dernière fois de réagir si
vous souhaitez rebondir sur certaines
choses allaient bouger les choses
vous savez j'aime pas trop j'aime pas
beaucoup l'expression français de souche
parce que tout dire et rien dire et puis
peu à peu être
j'ai dit je sais ce que ça veut dire
mais bon vous comprendrez par contre
dans votre imaginaire de français tous
fait ou pas avoir des français de toutes
les couleurs qui vivent en banlieue que
votre votre premier postulat est un peu
un point nos sens à ce que
le deuxième point le deuxième point je
suis pas dans sa tête je suis je regarde
les textes le deuxième point c'est par
rapport aux entreprises
c'est bien de vouloir aider la fiscalité
de vouloir baisser le coût mais il faut
savoir que le coût ne fait pas tout
les la compétitivité des entreprises ne
se fait pas que par le coup et se fait
aussi par la valeur elle se fait aussi
par une pluie plus de flexibilité
quand vous comparez la réglementation en
france et la réglementation en
angleterre par exemple qui est juste à
côté c'est pas du tout la même chose et
donc pouvait davantage vous développez
en angleterre et des pme vous en
connaissez pas visiblement mais des pme
qui délocalisent en angleterre il y en a
beaucoup
ainsi eu une réaction après
j'interviendrai sur le sujet particulier
font pas des généralités
jean-michel votre côté sur cette
question de réforme du droit du travail
les réformes ça fait depuis des années
qu on obéit réforme il faut faire à
chaque fois de plus en plus vite mais on
se pose jamais et on regarde jamais
qu'est ce qui se passe et pourquoi
est-ce qu'on est obligé de réformer
entre guillemets ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que l'étain de ne peut plus faire
grand chose en matière d'économie de
grand danger c'est les grandes
orientations de politiques et
économiques qui décident de l'avenir de
tout à chacun
et je crois que
il faut comment dire il se sert à rien
d'aller vite parce que on le voit bien
là bien constaté depuis des années on
fait vite avec sous sarkozy
c'était le président et qui voulait
réformer vite la france
et puis finalement le résultat il n'a
pas été au rendez vous le problème c'est
que il faut voir quels quelles sont les
interactions entre la situation de notre
pays et notre appartenance à l'europe
l'euro pour la politique étrangère à
l'otan donc réformer oui on sait que le
résultat il sera médiocre parce qu'on on
s'attaque aux conséquences et sans
jamais être été les causes
je pense sincèrement que on va faire de
nouvelles réformes avec de nouvelles
lois on va y gagner un petit peu mais de
façon générale on ira toujours vers une
augmentation de la pauvreté tous les ans
on a plus de 800000 personnes qui
tombent en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
on a de plus en plus de travailleurs
pauvres d des entreprises qui
délocalisent tous les jours constamment
mais ça il faut savoir pourquoi est-ce
qu'on en est arrivé là aujourd'hui
michel radis par voie là excusez moi on
remettra dans l'ordre veuillez m'excuser
je voulais revenir avec vous aussi
peut-être aussi sur ce ce postulat de de
votre formation il faut réinventer le
rapport au travail aussi et c'est une
réalité c'est une nécessité jeu
rebondissait ce que vous avez dit
vous-même également je signale
simplement qu'on n'a pas une seule fois
prononcé le mot de chômeurs et pourquoi
a t'on autant de chômeurs et pourquoi et
breton autant de personnes qui sont
laissés de côté est ce que je peux dire
c'est que tout revient sur la notion de
marché et le marché qui règle tous et
des heures travaillées qui
sont toujours constante alors que le
travail est de moins en moins bien
répartie donc une un travail concentré
sur lesquels beaucoup de gens se donnent
à fond quitte à faire des avc et puis
une portion de plus en plus grande de
travailleurs précaires
donc nouvelle donne c'est notamment
l'idée de pierre larrouturou c'est de
proposer de un partage du temps de
travail et une semaine qu'il n'est pas
en soi de quatre jours mais un équilibre
modulable et qui permettent aux
entreprises de dégager une valeur
ajoutée et de l'investir cette valeur
ajoutée dans l'économie réelle et non
pas dans l'économie financière
six axes routiers revenir encore sur
cette question du droit du travail
il supplée je donnais mon avis à mon
puis seulement juste par contre quand
même dire un point et c'est important
que les français le sachent je pense que
vous le savez malgré ce que vous dites
le travail l'économie c'est pas une part
du gâteau qui est limité et qu'on peut
se partager et l'économie c'est quelque
chose qui qui se développe qui grandit
on prend le cas j'en parlais qu'un taxi
ont parlé du cas du ber et alizée bah
oui finalement la part de marché qu
après hubert le chiffre d'affaires que
fait super en france et tous les toutes
les sociétés de vtc
il ne prend pas directement aux taxis
non il ya une activité qui s'est
développée avec des nouveaux entrants
donc partager le temps de travail c'est
le meilleur moyen de créer plus de
pauvres moi c'est pas est ce pas la
solution et je souhaite à très court
terme ou sacrées davantage de pauvreté
par la suite que ça détruit des secteurs
d'activité mais je vais revenir ce que
son je vais écrire était mon temps de
parole sur ce que je pense des dp de la
mesure et il ya une philosophie générale
sur ce que fait emmanuel macron et sur
le député que je veux être on a vu le
lendemain de l'élection d' emmanuel
macron fin du président de la république
qui a eu dans la rue directement des
personnes qui avaient manifesté pour
faire blocage à la politique à la
politique du président alors alors qu'il
n'avait même pas de deux discours même
pas de majorité
à l'assemblée nationale moi ce que je
veux c'est c'est vraiment le meilleur
pour le ps que n'ont pas on vient de
passer quinze années on a eu des
présidents désolé pour eux mais qu'ils
ont mené des politiques étaient assez
mauvaise
et là maintenant il faut éviter les
blocages en même temps il faut assurer
l'intérêt des français les négociations
par branche ou les négociations par
entreprises c'est ce qu'il faut parce
qu'ils ne sont nos entreprises sont en
compétition directement avec nos voisins
italiens avec nos voisins et le monde
voisin avait pris beaucoup d'avancé
minutes que je vous interromps pour la
suite si vous souhaitez horaires et du
côté de boue la france donc je suis sur
le point en effet que le travail n'est
pas un gâteau et que l'activité entraîne
l'activité sur cette thématique bondir
sur les négociations par entreprises
c'est quand même un sujet délicat
pas si j'en avais parlé mais j'ai pas le
temps d'entrer sur la suite n'ont cessé
ses négociations qui ont mené au sein
d'une entreprise ça fragilise déjà ceux
qui sont au sein d'entreprises parce
qu'ils ont menti il ya désormais des
organisations syndicales
ils sont quand même en direct avec avec
l'encadrement de l'entreprise les
responsables et dirigeants
c'est certainement pas facile a amené je
pense pas qu'il en sortira grand chose
si ce n'est peut-être quelques accords
mais sur l'activité je vois pas d'autres
solutions c'est quoi ces deux affaires
n'ont cessé c'est mieux que dès qu'il y
ait des accords de branche
plutôt que des accords qui seraient est
mené de façon locale par par des gens
qui sont qui sont peut-être indiqué
qu'ils connaissent le droit du travail
mais qui sont en situation de faiblesse
par rapport à l'entreprise jeudi dans la
même branche avait des entreprises
oui bah le même modèle économique qui
n'ont pas vraiment le muc la même
activité qui sont dans la même branche
comme ce couple est défini à lombez et
ensuite on veut on peut être sans
tricher mais en réalité quand vous
regardez bien on est en train de tout
compliquer alors donner de l'autonomie
avec le petit bout de la lorgnette et
est-ce qu'on n'est pas capable de
vraiment repenser la structure même du
travail la répartition du travail et je
suis un petit peu affolés par le votre
moi je suis pas une
une politicienne je suis pas je
travaille pas dans une entreprise je les
fais mais j'ai pas travailler très
longtemps pour des raisons diverses et
variées mais quand on parle à nouvelles
donnes du plan 1000 milliards pour le
climat bon c'est une façon pour les
entreprises d'intégrer les nouvelles
technologies pour développer les
économies pour aménager la consommation
de l'énergie je m'exprime pas très bien
mais c'est ça que je veux dire et
personne ne parle de remettre vraiment à
plat tout
tout s'est tu comment dire 7,7 gestion
du temps de travail
il est vraiment mal répartie seconde
thématique deuxième thématique
après on va parler de sécurité avec les
attentats qui se poursuivent
régulièrement encore du côté de
l'angleterre
emmanuel macron qui prévoit maintenant
la création d'une task force et l'elysée
il en a parlé pendant sa campagne les
choses devraient se préciser rapidement
un dispositif supplémentaire dans la
lutte contre le terrorisme et puis il ya
aussi l'état d'urgence et qui a été une
nouvelle fois prolongée
du côté de debout la france quelles
propositions vous portez et quel regard
vous portez sur les premières annonces
du gouvernement
bon tout d'abord il faudrait rappeler
que l'insécurité en france n'a pas
commencé avec le terrorisme ça fait des
années qu'elle que les français en
souffrent et pour nous une des raisons
c'est le laxisme judiciaire et celui ci
est aggravée par la surpopulation
carcérale
donc ça c'est un de mes sujets de
préoccupation majeure il faut savoir
qu'en france il ya environ 60000 places
de prison et qui est actuellement plus
de 70 mille prisonniers ce qui fait que
énormément de délinquant
multirécidiviste se relâcher dans la
nature sans même effectuer deux peines
de prison alors ya deux solutions et les
états unis qui
on choisit de construire toujours plus
de prison et qui ont tellement construit
qu'aujourd'hui 1 % de la population
américaine est en prison ça en france a
représenté 700 mille personnes en prison
c'est ce qui est dingue et ce à un coût
considérable
et puis à l'association de la solution
de la gauche qui consiste à tous vous
toujours trouver des excuses aux
criminels ou délinquants et à les
relâcher systématiquement parce que les
considèrent comme des victimes de la
société nous a dub ou la france on
souhaite se revenir sur une chose qui
avait été abrogée par nicolas sarkozy
qui ont été mises de l'intérieur c'était
ce qu'on appelait à l'époque la double
peine c'était tout simplement qu'un
étranger qui avait commis un crime ou un
délit et bien été expulsés de france est
interdite territoire après avoir purgé
sa peine on propose une solution encore
plus simple encore plus économique c'est
que tout étranger ayant commis un crime
ou un délit grave en france
et bien soit expulsé interdite
territoire faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui il
ya 18 % d'étrangers dans les prisons
françaises
donc ça libérerait tout de suite très
une place de prison on voit ces mesures
de bon sens qui règlerait en gros une
grosse partie des problèmes d'insécurité
si vous souhaitez réagir et vous pensez
qu'on est dans l'europe
et vous pensez qu'on est dans le monde
avec un raisonnement comme ça c'est à
dire bah je crois que vous m'avez bien
compris je voulais mettre je pense au
gspc les étrangers soit disant certains
ont commis des crimes ou certains sont
malhonnêtes
bien sûr mais de là à les virer de nos
prisons et de l'airé expulsé je
comprends pas très bien votre logique un
étranger en france et un invité et donc
il a abondé vidéo ou les ligneurs ait en
france ils sont tous invités
abbas s'est on n'a aucune raison de
l'accepter si s'il commet un crime ou un
délit si elle accepte elle est un
touriste âgé à condition qu'ils se
comportent bien tout simplement à former
un mouvement de migration
un continent qui se comporte bien tout
simplement ça c'est du bon sens
moi si je vais à l'étranger me comporte
bien pensé tout et ça fait des étrangers
qui travaillent équipage et peut-être
contraire à notre production
là je pars bientôt une bonne sécurité
mais cet étranger vous n'allez pas tous
les mettre dans leur en prison bien je
veux pas les mettre en prison je sais ce
que je dis je dis que les étrangers et
qu'ils ont commis un crime ou un délit
sont expulsés interdit de territoire se
taire vous ne faites pas de confiance à
notre justice par un crime on a dédié et
comment ils réagissent vraiment il est
jugé ils n'ont pas le droit de passer
devant un tribunal si bien sûr justement
quand ils opèrent un étranger condamné
pour un crime ou un délit est expulsé en
point c'est tout et vous l'expliquer
c'est nous essayez vous l'expliqué dans
son pays d'origine et c'est ce qu'ils
avaient vu en france et à casque à
nicolas sarkozy la broche qu'on utilise
et après ça va faire une grève de
terroristes et ça va alimenter dans son
village
ça va nous retomber dessus tout les
l'effet boomerang tous les chiffres de
la délinquance sont des gones terrorise
offrez-vous autant d'arguments mais
j'aimerais que tu sais ce que vous ne
vous arrête tous les deux du côté de de
l'upm vous avez une autre approche
facile et celle de renouer avec une
politique de paix oui tout à fait on
veut renouer avec une politique de paix
comment vous dire jeux jeux comme un
revenir sur la question du terrorisme et
la sécurité
il faut il faut deux il faut augmenter
les moyens de la police de la justice de
la gendarmerie des services de
renseignement parce que c'est ce qu'ils
font quand même un travail
extraordinaire
il faut savoir que l'état d'urgence qui
a été renouvelée huit fois non seulement
il n'est pas il n'est pas bien
appliquées mais en supplément il n'a pas
à porter ses fruits
si si ce n'est aussi une augmentation
des libertés publiques
une diminution excusez-moi des libertés
publiques
on surveille toute la population on
commence à ficher tout le monde on
rentre dans une société de défiance ou
finalement tout le monde doit se méfier
de tout le monde
la criminologie ça fait depuis des
années qu elle existe on sait qu'on sait
pertinemment que n'importe qui peut
passer à l'acte
un jour ou l'autre c'est ce qui fait
c'est ce qui fait peur quand on regarde
les choses un peu en profondeur les
juges les légers les professionnels de
deux polices voyais arriver des crimes
il devant eux qui viennent de tout
horizons de la société civile donc ce
problème on le connaît depuis longtemps
on le le terrorisme c'est autre chose
c'est c'est encore plus compliqué et
c'est il ya une interférence
international bon ccc pas pardon j'ai
pas entendu ce que conclut et sur votre
idée de ce que vous dépassez deux temps
par akalé dit non non non je suis tout
s'est très bien s'est dit que ça qu'on
parle dans 7 à vous alors d'abord pour
revenir ce que vous avez dit par rapport
à la task force du président de la
république
moi je pense qu'il faut être vigilant
sur sur ceux sur cette task force c'est
peut-être quelque chose de très bien
parce qu'il faut une action de
coordination dans les dents les
opérations qu'on avait pu
malheureusement à voir et même dans les
actions de surveillance et de prévention
jeudi vigilant parce qu'il faut pas que
cette taskforce fassent doublon avec les
avec les organisations qui actuellement
et qui travaillent pour nous défendre
contre le terrorisme
après en tant que député qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire on a en a trois domaines il
ya l'action internationale or ça c'est
du ressort du président de la république
il y a l'activité de répression en
france l activité de prévention sur
l'activité
sur l'activité nationale et de
répression désolé c'est pas un tacle que
je ferme mon voisin mais avant de penser
aux étrangers qui sont en prison en
france je pense qu'il faut davantage
penser aux français qu'ils vont revenir
de théâtre de guerre notamment de syrie
qu'est ce qu'on fait de ces personnes là
quand c'est des personnes qui ont
déclaré qu'ils ont brûlé leurs
passeports déclaré la guerre à la france
il faut avoir une action qui est ferme
pas fermée mais qui est ferme alors que
ce quelqu'un qui a voulu faire la guerre
à la france où le juger comme il se doit
ensuite sur l'action de l'action de
répression on a un état d'urgence qui si
je peux me permettre je transposerait au
plan vigipirate
dans la mesure où il dure et risque de
durer très longtemps
c'est un état d'urgence qui est utile et
nécessaire dans certains domaines mais
qui dans d'autres domaines crée une
atteinte aux libertés fondamentales et
des personnes qui qui sont assignés à
résidence sans avoir eu un seul jugement
c'est impossible pouvait pas travailler
et être assigné à résidence mais de
l'autre côté vous pouvez pas libéré tout
le monde donc il faut il faut prendre ce
qui est positif dans l'état d'urgence
pour le maintenir je vais heurter
certaines personnes pour le pour le
maintenir un plus plus longtemps dans la
durée et dans ce domaine là je pense
notamment à ce qu'on peut faire dans la
percussion dans la perquisition des
données informatiques et ea dernier
point après je vous laisse la dame
aurait pas dans les points il ya une
action de prévention et en tant que
député ma réserve parlementaire servir à
ça justement parce que l'attachement à
la république il se fait il se fait
souvent dans les associations quel que
soit le domaine et jeffrey tâte encore
votre carte blanche je voulais réagir à
les signaler que la réserve
parlementaire supprimer apparemment
aujourd'hui je voudrais juste réagir sur
l'axé international qui relève du
président c'est un petit peu mais
connaître nos institutions d'un
parlement et malheureusement je regrette
beaucoup va je regrette qu'il ne soit
pas plus souvent consultés et que nous
ayons par exemple des actions militaires
en libye dans le zig et auront comme
c'est le président qui décide d'envoyer
de force ou non mais nous sommes dans
une démocratie on doit basculer
grasset oui mais le nommé chef des
armées s'est présenté république
d'accord dont la lutte elle que
l'actrice morte et je m'inquiétais un
petit peu testeront oui très bien on
peut pas intervenir n'importe où dans le
monde sans avoir un mandat des nations
unies simon cc stemi guerre inégale
je vais voir autant de paroles
respectifs et ensuite nous passerons à
la carte blanche de chacun chacune un
peu près une minute chacun pour pouvoir
vous exprimer sur cette carte blanche et
pour réagir aussi à celles des autres si
vous le souhaitez si on peut voir donc
les chronomètres vous êtes tous a à peu
près à cinq minutes si ce n'est se dit
ça court vous êtes presque à 6 minutes
un peu plus de six minutes même on va
les voir qu'ils vont s'afficher dans un
instant on va commencer avec vous pour
debout la france quelle est la carte
blanche le sujet que vous souhaitez
mettre en avant le plus dans cette
campagne voilà vous êtes tous à peu près
plus ou moins cinq minutes sans vous je
vous disais sinon comme je l'aï déjà dit
nous est debout la france
on souhaite rappeler aux français
quelque chose qu'on ne rappelle pas
assez souvent c'est qu'ils peuvent être
fiers de leur pays ils ont habité un
pays magnifique
ils ont un héritage considérable un
héritage artistique culturel littéraire
scientifique extrêmement riche et cet
héritage nous oblige il nous oblige
d'abord être digne de l'assumer et
surtout il nous oblige à le transmettre
aux générations futures
pour ça on doit en finir avec la
repentance mémorielle cette repentance
qui emmanuel macron entretien lorsqu'il
va ans né en algérie qu'il déclare que
la france est coupable de crimes contre
l'humanité nous on en a marre on n'en
veut plus cette repentance qui
culpabilise nos enfants pour les dépô t
de l'heure de leur identité
eh bien on veut y mettre un terme et au
contraire on veut leur apprendre à aimer
leur histoire qui est belle nous devons
également cesser la bétonisation de
notre pays et l'extension anarchique des
zones commerciales qui enlaidissent la
france et enfin sur le thème de
l'immigration
il ya deux périls tout d'abord tous ces
jeunes français qui titre la france
parce qu'ils ne trouvent plus leur place
et qu'on n'a pas assez appris à aimer
leur pays et enfin l'immigration massive
que subit la france à auquel il faut
mettre un terme car c'est une
catastrophe sur tous les plans de
catastrophe au niveau de la sécurité
une catastrophe
pour le niveau scolaire une catastrophe
environnementale une catastrophe
financière et enfin une catastrophe avec
le terrorisme qu'on connaît depuis
quelques années
donc pour toutes ces raisons moi je
répète encore une fois que je souhaite
redonner leur fierté aux français et les
appeler à faire tout tout en leur
possible pour transmettre cette fierté
de leur pays
une fois de plus si chacun a souhaité
s'exprimer sur le sujet ou passez votre
carte blanche mais je sais que vous avez
vu que vous souhaitiez réagir
heureusement je crois que vous êtes une
belle machine à fabriquer des
clandestins je n'en dirai pas plus
votre carte blanche à ma carte blanche
elle est justement sur les migrants et
je voudrais souligner le travail qui a
été fait par les associations de
bénévoles dans les yvelines pour
l'accueil humain social car chacun doit
avoir un toit
et lorsque les gens sont capables les
essaye d'accompagner les personnes dans
les lourdes démarches administratives
je voudrais également qu'on a on l'a pas
mentionné heureusement mais je sais que
c'est dans le discours ambiant qu'on
parle de gestion de flux migratoires ces
personnes ne sont pas des marchandises
il faut respecter respecter la dignité
et la liberté de circulation
c'est un principe indéniable qu'il faut
pas pas du tout éliminer
je sais qu'on évitera pas cette
migration comme vous dites je m'adresse
particulièrement à vous dans cet
eldorado que beaucoup croient trouver
dans l'europe et je crois que vous avez
peur notamment lorsque vous mentionnez
ce qui s'est passé en algérie
vous avez un problème avec votre
conscience comme beaucoup d'autres
français et je crois que vous avez peur
de vous frotter aux gens qui ont fui la
guerre les tortures les conditions
climatiques qui font qu'ils n'ont plus
de travail et qui meurent dans des
heurts dans le sahara etc et j'en parle
d'autant plus que je n'ai pas fait dans
ma présentation je ne dis pas pourquoi
voter pour moi mais pourquoi je me
présente je suis bénévole en
responsabilité depuis plusieurs années
auprès des migrants et pour le respect
de la dignité humaine
et j'ajoute encore une chose quand vous
dites que beaucoup de jeunes français
partent à l'extérieur parce qu'il n'aime
pas assez notre pays c'est
malheureusement parce qu'ils aiment leur
pays qui n'y trouvent pas de place qui
nous trouvent pas de travail que deux
qui partent et pour des raisons
économiques
ce faisant ils auront laissé répondre je
vous laisse justement répondre puisque
on s'est adressé plusieurs vrai avoue
donc candidat debout la france qui
réagit ensuite ce sera à vous par
rapport à l'accueil des migrants bien
sûr c'est totalement utopique et ne pas
réfléchir à long terme
il ya plus de 5 milliards d'êtres
humains qui ont un niveau de vie
inférieur a reçu de la france
est ce qu'on la france et ya pas d avis
qu 1,5 milliard d'êtres humains non ça
n'a aucun sens donc à un moment il faut
regarder la réalité en face et penser au
pays de nos enfants avant de penser aux
autres
si sakho votre carte blanche vous aurez
un petit peu moins de temps je vais
ensuite je vais très court mais je veux
dire ce que je défends de soissons c'est
très simple c'est une politique
d'innovation qui est ambitieuse et
globale
si je suis député je regarderai tous les
textes de loi pour favoriser d'une part
l'innovation française et d'autre part
nous aider à atteindre nos objectifs ce
soit en agriculture en santé en finances
publiques en modernisation de l'état et
c'est sur ce point là c'est je pense le
meilleur moyen de ne pas subir
l'innovation d'anticiper une politique
ses meilleurs super moyens de ne pas
subir ne pas détruire des emplois et de
ne pas faire les erreurs qu'on a pu
faire pour la mondialisation basma carte
blanche et je conclurai trio passe avon
pour le prg que vous portez que vous
mettez en avant dans cette campagne que
vous souhaitez mettre en avant dans
cette campagne une monnaie une
ce serait la modernisation
de la démocratie de la vie politique
d'une part avec l'instauration du
référendum d'initiative populaire ou à
500 me une personne en déposant
signature en mairie pourrait
demandez ce qu'est un référendum sur tel
ou tel autre sujet la reconnaissance
pleine et entière et révocatoire du vote
blanc et l'obligation pour chaque élu
d'avoir un casier judiciaire vierge
le non cumul des mandats on va limiter
le cumul à deux mandats consécutifs
je vois là et il est temps de passer à
une conclusion en amont et le fait que
nouvelles donnes propose de que ce soit
soumis aux citoyens des citoyens tirés
au sort donc satisfaite ce que vous en
pensez de cette proposition c'est
l'occasion d'échanger entre vous aussi
pour les téléspectateurs
[Musique]
ce que j'en pense oui c'est intéressant
mais bon
faites très bien mais il faut peut-être
aussi limité utilisation du 49 3 il est
peut-être utilisé un peu trop souvent
pour aller vite parce qu'il faut aller
vite et pas réfléchir souvent et pas à
pas laissé le temps de la réflexion tout
à chacun on passe à vos conclusions une
trentaine de secondes chacun puisque
vous êtes tous à peu près entre 6
minutes 30 et 7 minutes de temps de
parole ça va s'afficher pendant que vous
commencez à répondre s'ils disent ah kow
la conclusion est pour vous trente à
quarante cinq secondes pour conclure ce
débat voilà les temps qui sévit en
conclusion j'aimerais dire aux citoyens
que j'ai leur offre la possibilité de
passer d'une circonscription où on avait
une république des partis à une
circonscription dans une république des
citoyens
avec moi il n'y a pas de question de
parti des deux partis politiques
j'écouterai tous les citoyens pour
défendre leurs voix à l'assemblée
nationale en fonction de leurs
compétences et des soutiens qu'ils ont
dans leur domaine l'autre point c'est
que je veillerai très particulièrement
aux finances publiques ça fait huit ans
que je travaille sur cette question là
en plus des politiques d'innovation et
de soutien aux entreprises parce que que
l'on regarde la nouvelle manière de
faire de travailler ou non il faut que
tout le monde est un emploi même si
c'est difficile ou voire impossible de
la voir il faut que la majorité des
citoyens est un emploi et qu'on arrive à
ré inverser la tendance de la population
active sans michel breil oui pour les pm
votre conclusion
ma conclusion
voici énormément de choses à faire en
france je crois qu'on va pas
suffisamment en profondeur dans les
analyses on regarde pas suffisamment
ce qui ce qui se passe et on a tendance
à aller vite
c'est enfin on est parti dans une course
en avant sans aucune réflexion
donc j'ai et pis en plus il n'y a pas
assez de débat politique on dispute pas
suffisamment des questions du bien
commun de la moralisation de la vie
politique de nos actions militaires à
gauche à droite et des conséquences que
tout ça peut avoir sur notre quotidien
il faut aussi ses députés et les
représentants de la nation au sens au
sein de l'hémicycle
il faut savoir représenter tout le monde
voir qu'est ce qui est qu'est ce qui est
le mieux pour le bien collectif et c'est
la chose avec elle je m'attacherai à
trop brouillons à présent en votant pour
moi et pour debout la france est bien
nos concitoyens voteront pour un parti
qu'ils savent patriotes et qui porte des
valeurs de droite tels que la
responsabilité l'ordre la liberté et la
justice
et pour vous écouter on parle de
législatives alors moi j'ai envie de
dire un petit adage qu'on connaît tous
think global act local et c'est pas une
perception dépasser l'action lé locale
mais toujours avec une bonne
compréhension du monde et nous
souhaitons à nouvelles donnes poursuivre
sur cette voie nous reposant sur la
dynamique des territoires sur les
populations locales le tissu associatif
pour innover rénover améliorer et
toujours pour défendre nos libertés
les je n'ai pas la prétention de défend
de deux îles de divisionnaire les
lecteurs et d'occulter les très grandes
différences qu'il ya entre candidats
professionnels et candy et militants
citoyens mais j'entends un sikh nouvelle
donne évidemment et au sein nouvelles
donnes défendre la biodiversité
démocratique entre guillemets on en
parle beaucoup de biodiversité et le
droit des petites formations comme des
grandes de porter ce projet deux
conceptions de gouvernement qui soit
novatrice et qu'ils fassent évoluer une
société dans le bon sens merci à tous
les quatre d'avoir participé merci aux
candidats qui était présent aussi sur le
premier plateau l'étang paroles qui
s'affichent le temps que je
vous rappelle que le 11 juin dimanche 11
juin à partir de 19h30 sur tv fil 78 2
vous pourrez suivre la grande soirée des
législatives avec les résultats en temps
réel sur la 1re 2e 3e 10e 11e et 12e
circonscription ne jetteront aussi un
oeil avec nos partenaires de bpm menthe
radio locale sur ce qui se passe dans
nord du département cette soirée sera
aussi diffusée sur radio sensations et
hervé eux dans le sud du département
merci donc encore une fois à vous demain
à la même heure c'est nicolas
kirillovitch qui recevra les candidats
de la 10e circonscription très belle
soirée
[Musique]